that's not really a martial arts is it
it's not a martial it's for well-being
all right if you like well-being so
what's all this what does this do it's
meditative so this isn't when they're
doing this that's not a [__] Punch
coming in no no man okay no not
necessarily yeah but but is Tai Chi it's
considered a martial arts maybe it is
listed as a martial arts but but what
I'm saying is like this is very American
to think of martial arts in terms of
killing someone else right not only in
America it's a defensive no because
martial arts
thank you it's a psychological practice
like you it's all mental health yeah
it's it let me see something American
it's not American all right the whole
purpose of kung fu even though it's
defense this is America it's not
American dude listen to whatever I'll
let you finish because you're getting
angry I'm not getting angry I might need
to use some self-defense I'll let you
finish I'll let you finish that all
right what I'm saying is that fine these
[__] martial arts were created for a
defense for being defensive right but
it's still created to hurt somebody wait
it's very at a point go ahead I think we
have the best martial arts Filipino yeah
machetes
I don't know machetes was a martial art
fantastic
all the weapons fighting yeah yeah Kali
iskrima Arnis yeah Filipinos holy [__]
it's killer yeah so what you're so but
I'm all I'm asking is fundamentally is
Tai Chi a martial art yes no you see
this is a very American okay explain
that it's very American to think of
martial arts in terms of like how
effective can I kill this other person
with it if I can't kill this if I can't
win the UFC Championship then this is
[__] is a very American way of
thinking about martial arts okay so
because because if you want to win uh
the UFC Championship yeah you're already
okay first of all in UFC you're already
discounting the fact of like multiple
combatants you know like it's one-on-one
there's a referee don't kick you in the
dick you know there's rules I'm not
saying it's not effective they'll beat
the [__] over anybody it's like it's
like saying I got this shotgun right and
I meditate with it no no that's also
very American
idea yeah right now the whole purpose no
it's not because for defense okay even
the Arts is restraint practice
practicing a discipline I'm gonna
straight not shooting this guy with a
shotgun
what is martial arts to you so it is for
combat but also to get those skills for
combat it is also for spirituality and
it's all I understand that discipline
what I'm saying though right
all I've seen is this right how is this
gonna hurt anybody because you are
meditating and trying to be calm while
doing that and restraint and then in a
real fight you need to be elusive Bruce
Lee Be Like Water you know that scene in
sicario yeah I've seen the movie when
they go like nothing will make sense to
American years
that's what's going on right now because
if you're thinking about like
if you think about martial arts like
cars okay
Canada
I know it's very American to not
understand their accents
guess what Ronnie you're in America yeah
right why don't you change for us
[Laughter]
right you don't have to be anything
other American you are in America right
now thank you you've done very well for
yourself in your garage in your podcast
you don't need it no you don't need me
to tell I'm just saying I'm gonna try to
give you my perspective yeah but I'm
tired coming into my [__] girl trying
telling me what I'm what I'm not and
that's not welcoming the foreigners into
your garage then no I'm glad you're here
what's up with not editing in La that's
what Neil Brennan in these [__] hoity
toys do yeah right we we edit in this
[__] podcast you can't do 20 more
minutes no I can't do 20 minutes in this
garage
we're [__] uh the angriest guy let's
just let's go back to what I my American
mindset okay so in terms of martial arts
okay if you're thinking about cars okay
uh F1 car will beat any other kind of
planet all the time F1 is like iPhone
cars like mixed martial arts if you
train MMA every single day you will beat
anyone else one one probably any other
martial is one one but like the
dedication and the destruction to your
body that you need to do to maintain
that level is it worth is that what you
want to live your whole life doing in an
MMA gym no so the alternative is why not
drive a BMW or Mercedes for example Wing
Chun or Brazilian Jiu Jitsu or something
else where you can enjoy your life and
still get to where you need to go can I
go Prius yeah but but if you fight if
you use a Mercedes to fight F1 yeah
you're not going to win but that's like
saying so we should all only drive F1
cars uh there's other cars that might
suit your day-to-day life not all of us
want to destroy our shins kicking banana
trees so Tai Chi is Prius Tai Chi would
be like I don't know it'd be like a
smart car a Smart car a Smart car but
again this whole thing is like that's
what you get out of it maybe you get
calmness out of it maybe you get you
know for people who only sit in their
garages doing podcasts you get some
movement out of it right you get off
your ass and you get to move a little
bit as opposed to sitting down doing
three hour podcasts every single day
right yeah and also there's a whole lot
of like like getting angry and angry
inside yeah I'm not I'm not even talking
about angry I'm not even talking about
you I'm saying that instead of seeing
your garage getting angry and angry and
not moving you could go and do tai chi
and let go of anger and have some
movement with your body because there's
a whole lot of like think about it Bobby
you because he does yoga you're really
good at yoga you love it thank you but
then how Tai Chi's similar there's a lot
of intentionality behind every move like
you're very connected I know but yoga
what is it is it a martial arts there's
you know I mean yoga was no one did I'm
gonna do a [__] downward dog right
and this is going to defend against that
[__] well right now if you did a
downward dog I did it in front of a knee
kick if someone did a knee kick and I
did a downward dog as the guy as the guy
who has actually been in a fight that
would be ridiculous right okay all I'm
asking it was Tai Chi created as a as a
no but the premise is very American okay
so let me answer a question you can use
type okay
you've re-proven a point here that you
cannot use if you use Tai Chi you can't
beat Jon Jones in the UFC heavyweight
championship okay you want to hear it
it's pointless okay great it's taichi
pointless yes it is well I mean some
people in this room could probably
benefit from it example you know moving
and and letting go of anger but hey you
know what do I know I'm just a [__]
Foreigner right
because yoga was from India which is
where Buddhism came from and then
Buddhism spread to China and they
brought the yoga with them so that's why
the Shaolin Kung Fu has yoga elements
they do a lot of stretching and all that